foreign
[Music]
hey folks
hope everyone is doing well hope you had
a lovely weekend I did it was
packed it was
really packed but it was good
uh dark wheat beer you can keep that one
for yourself Gozer I think
hello everybody Molly Miss Wicked Wolf
hey Caroline homebody
Angus hey Meg good to see you
Hades Mr nameless
the Goji Ed Jason ikari kid boy we got a
nice talkative group here today Jackson
255 A.D
ah
Adult Swim announced they plan to recast
Rick and Morty chance and how that of
that working ryland's performance is a
massive part of those characters some
episodes are just him riffing put to
animation
so setting aside my own feelings about
Rick and Morty which is that I've never
liked it and actually that dialogue
style that improv that improvisational
dialogue style is a huge part of why I I
never liked it uh but the idea of
recasting it seems very foolish
um even if you could get people who
could recreate the voice you know the
the sound of it given that so much of uh
what it was built around was just him
you know doing whatever he felt like
this light's a little bright
there we go and them sort of sorting out
what that was going to look like later
it's not just a matter of the voices
that was part of his creative input into
the whole thing I can't imagine it's
going to work very well at all
yeah
you wake up in the last TV show you
watched this is your life now where are
you what was the last thing I watched
thank you
I think
I think it was Doctor Who
so I guess I'll be okay
uh I thank you uh Phantom Angel of Music
thank you very much
I appreciate that I'm guessing Adult
Swim shows I've never really been my
thing
um
as far as their original Productions go
by and large not really like I enjoyed
in here's the thing when I liked them it
was
it was usually in the very small doses
that they were offered it so like I did
like Aqua Teen Hunger Force but the
episodes were only like 15 minutes long
back when I was watching it so like that
was about as much as I could handle more
than that like I tried to watch the
movie
good grief
um but yeah the the way a lot of their
original Productions went over time and
the more surrealistic bent like I I very
much appreciate
what Adult Swim swim did with its
original Productions
but yeah most of them weren't to my
tastes uh despite the way a lot of
people like them despite being actually
long time friends with someone who
worked on one of the dang things but you
know
how was the Burlesque Festival it was
good it was exhausting I I did uh I was
a stage kitten for two shows uh
back-to-back nights and uh
so the first night I had sort of a cut
off flannel it was you know kind of a
kind of vermonte pseudo
lumberjack-esque kind of look and
um my intention was to wear you know
just some you know big Stompy you know
brown boots that I had you know just
sort of stomp around the wood kind of
boots
the problem was they were too big to fit
in my bag so I had them set by the door
intending to grab them on my way out
I wasn't gonna wear them to the show
because then because of the weather they
were going to get dirty and slushy and
snowy and then they they would have
caused him that would have messed up the
stage I would have had to clean them so
that's why I didn't do that but I forgot
to grab them on the way out that didn't
mean I was without shoe options but it
meant I wore
heels for two nights in a row when it
was my intention to only wear them for
one night and my feet are not happy with
me
at all
uh would I be the doctor or companion in
my face I I tend to think of myself more
as wanting to be the doctor in general
I'll admit to that
started a friend on who with the 11th
Hour uh even I'm surprised how well that
and the Beast below work as his thesis
statement and style Flex right out of
the gate yeah no series five was was
actually a very good jumping on point
Adults Swim home movies and space ghosts
the end oh that works Meg
um
most of today's conversations will be in
relation to the Oscar nominations oh
I keep forgetting those are out and I
looked at them I looked at the nominees
and I still keep forgetting that they
came out
uh there were two major omissions that I
would have liked to have seen I really
would have liked to seen a nomination
for Keke Palmer for nope and I really
would have liked to have seen a
nomination for Janelle Monae for Glass
Onion that having been said the latter
one's not well neither is that
surprising the former's in a horror
movie which the Oscars tend to overlook
and the latter is in a franchise that
the Oscars already did Dirty to its uh
to its uh lead character you know who
wasn't
um played by Daniel Craig because last
time they they uh snubbed anadarmus
so you know I guess I shouldn't have
been
too shocked by that I was pleasantly
surprised at how well-rounded uh the
nominations for things like everything
everywhere all at once were like they
didn't snub Stephanie Sue and only
nominate Jamie Lee Curtis granted only
one person can win so depending on how
that goes maybe that'll be different but
that was nice to see I would have liked
to have seen some more nominations for
rrr it did at least get the nomination
for best song which God
dang it it really needed it really
needed to have
um and Angela Bassett being nominated
for black panther was one of those
things that I'm like this is the this is
a nomination that should happen and
won't
but it did and I'm really glad because
she
killed it in that movie she absolutely
killed it did I watch Velma no
good grief no nothing nothing about that
looked appealing to me at all it looked
like it was made by people who didn't
seem to actually like Scooby Doo and
most of the reviews I've watched or read
since then kind of bear out that
instinctual gut feeling I had so no
that's that's on the um I'll only watch
it if someone pays me pile
uh
uh sorry my nose that just
let's see
my big early prediction for the Oscar
ceremony that performance uh not two
notches gonna shut the show down it
should
if they've they oh they better perform
it too because they've been iffy about
actually performing the songs lately
like if you're gonna not if you're gonna
nominate that song you better make a
freaking production
about it my goodness
uh
any thoughts on Velma I kind of agree
with anyone that's not very good I mean
other than just what I saw in trailers
told me that I probably wasn't gonna
like it and I avoided it I don't really
have any thoughts beyond that
uh
is the Beast below just the ones who
walk away uh from uh Amela drawn out I'm
not sure because I don't I'm not
familiar with what you're referencing
there
uh
let's see oh John vinyls thank you very
much for the Super Chat greatly
appreciated
Tumblr culture is complaining endlessly
about the Disney corporate culture while
celebrating the work of its artists
employees and their creative Works
Disney is
Disney is difficult and this is honestly
this is kind of coming up as I continue
to hammer on uh the issues with
um
you know supporting things like Hogwarts
Legacy
so
Disney is an awkward one to talk about
because
it is first of all blanket statement
it is too big a company it should not be
as big as it is it should never have
been allowed to be as big as it became
it should be broken up take that as a
given all right let's start with that
I feel like there's a tendency by people
especially by anti-woke folks to
particularly hammer on Disney because
Disney is trying to appeal to a more
politically conscious uh audience and in
addition to the fact that Disney is not
the worst
on those things overall
so
here's the thing I often find myself
when I talk about other similar
corporate entities like say Warner
Brothers Discovery much to my own
Chagrin
I have to end up
praising Disney if only by comparison
not in a vacuum in a vacuum Disney
especially if you want to take a full
scope at you know they're decades like
100 years worth of existence lots a lot
to criticize
but at the same time like
I frequently have to point to them as
like okay
they do handle this crap better most of
the time and I hate that
I hate having to do that
and
there is there's both a validity and a
difficulty in criticizing a corporate
culture corporate culture while
celebrating
um the artistic works because
they are
often not always but often somewhat
detached from each other
you know the corporate culture doesn't
really care about the art other than is
it making us money
and the artists unless the corporate
culture is directly encroaching on them
doesn't have to think about them too
much now that does still happen we know
we saw things that came out
um you know when when things got more
scrutinized where they don't say gay
Bill and then a number of people working
for Disney owned corporations talked
about how they wanted to include things
like more queer representation and were
specifically barred from doing so by
Disney higher-ups so like that's that's
where it crosses over but I do
understand the
impulse to want to protect the artistic
Minds
even as you rail against the corporate
ones
and I get that instinct
sometimes it is more viable a thing to
do than others
sometimes
it's really not worth trying to separate
them other times there are clearer
distinctions it's messy is the simple
reality like all of this is
freaking messy absolutely no Corporation
is above reproach Disney especially
and if you want to get into all the
things of you know you you know or even
just me you know I talk about Marvel and
I well not lately but I have
historically praised a fair amount of
Marvel fair amount of Disney animated
stuff
um and all that
but
at the same time
if you were to tell me I'd have less of
that in my life but we will break up the
Disney Corporation
I'd take that trade in a freaking
heartbeat happily I will not defend that
company
but I do still support it
and unfortunately Financial ways now
I'll still make my arguments about
things like Hogwarts Legacy because
that's a like the thing is people try
and compare that to Disney and they're
not comparable because Hogwarts Legacy
has a direct money funnel to JK Rowling
who is using her wealth to make trans
people's lives as difficult and
miserable as humanly possible and to
code and to help codify that into law
like that's a very straight line
scenario Disney there's a lot more to
entangle does it mean it's not worth
untangling no it probably is but it's
it's Messier
it's just so much Messier
I hate capitalism
global capitalism is all of that writ
large
anyways
do I watch Bluey I've seen clips of
Bluey that I've enjoyed I have not
watched the show proper
is there a name for the archetype about
a wimpy character becoming a monster uh
EG Jason from Far Cry The Seventh Doctor
Walter White Wesley from Angel probably
um
I would think
well first of all I don't think the
Seventh Doctor fits your criteria
because he's a bit more of a case of we
realized how Machiavellian he'd always
been and that became clearer but as far
as the rest go
um
it's it's kind of a it's a version of
corrupted by power
it's not that straightforward though
there probably is
um
it probably is
named something more specific
but I I don't know what it is
the one who the one
the ones who walk away from a malice is
about a city where life is perfect
because they torture a child
yeah yeah in that case the Beast blow is
definitely the same core idea certainly
uh
uh strange new worlds didn't know my
last episode last year they did they did
and I actually immediately thought of
that and actually the image of that
popped into my dang head yeah yeah they
did
uh let's see
have you heard Roger Craig Smith as
Batman I think he's a great man to take
up the cape and cow uh lookup he's
working on Arkham Origins
I am not familiar with this person and I
don't think that I have uh like I
given at this point how bad my
um
motion sickness has gotten I'm I just
I've kind of given up on the idea that
I'm going to be able to get into
the um
the Arkham games and so it's hard for me
to
care
[Laughter]
uh
oh wow
I'm at least happy that Diane Warren got
an honorary Oscar at the governor's
award so I don't feel too bad for her uh
getting them and not winning for 14th
time oh well that's good
uh
255 a d thank you very much for the
Super Chat I've seen Avatar 2 now
there's this Navi tribe that are coded
Polynesians some of them are played by
white actors does that count as black
face
ha
so before I say anything before I say
anything
opinion of a white person should never
supersede the opinion of any people of
color especially anyone from the
Polynesian regions or the place that
they're being coded from so no matter
what I say
low priority opinion
let's establish that
my own personal call on that would be
no
but not in Leica it's all good situation
more in a
I think in a case like that it would be
enough to address the coding and how
well or
um fairly or uh stereotypically that was
or wasn't done
um
it to me at least it feels like a bit of
an overstep
to when because part of the part of the
reason to code characters and you can
have an argument over a racial coding is
a good idea or not we can have a whole
separate conversation about that but
part of the reason coding exists is so
that you can draw on the Notions of a
thing without having to literally
recreate that thing so if you've already
created something that is coded as
something but like they're already you
know I mean they're blue
they're what they're eight foot tall and
blue so I
getting into a black face argument on
that
again if somebody actually from that
um culture wanted to make that argument
I would not stand in their way but to me
that feels like splitting hairs well
there's probably more than enough to
pull apart with just talking about how
good or bad the coding in and of itself
is if that makes sense
there are rabbit tracks in my area oh
that's nice it's mostly squirrel tracks
in the snow around here
The Exorcist is 50 mind blown ah
I have seen The Exorcist
it's it's fine
like it's like I get why it was kind of
a big deal especially in horror at the
time but it's one of those movies that
like I can't by the time I saw it I was
an adult I'd seen stuff that had taken
influence from it it seemed dated to me
it seemed well done it just and it's not
impossible for me to to Really to really
get hit hard by movies of that age or
anything
um close to it like the
uh the 1976 I think Invasion of the Body
Snatchers I still think is the scariest
movie of all time
and that thing's older than I am so it's
not impossible for horror from that time
to to hit me quite hard that one never
quite did though
I think maybe it's also because I wasn't
raised in any religion like most of the
people I know who are like oh it
terrified me either were catholic or
were ex-catholics or were in some way
more inherently religious than I am or
was or ever probably will be so you know
I I suspect
um that there's a there's a bit of that
impacting
um
how hard it hit other people
honestly after Mulan I've given up on
Disney I'm assuming you mean the
live-action remake
because the original is pretty good
I watched Jesse's video on Avatar uh uh
the way of water I saw that it was up I
haven't seen it I
um I have not seen that movie yet I
don't know if I'm gonna get to it uh
while it's still in theaters we'll we'll
see
we we shall see
um I didn't skip a Super Chat uh 255 A.D
I was trying to catch up to it so give
me a minute and I will get there
personal question making my own comic
any advice for someone who's not sure if
I'm doing it right
the only way to know if you're doing it
right is to get it done and
get the opinions of people you trust
um I I think it's I think it's important
um
for most creators especially anything
you have to sink a lot of time into to
have people that you you can trust
their opinions on so like
I have with my videos I have
um I have somebody very trusted who I
will have
um you know take a look at my videos
before they go live to try and catch
things that I I might have missed
um if I have a video that's like on a
more sensitive topic that I'm kind of
stepping out of my Lane I might run it
by a couple of people with relevant
knowledge
um you know when uh well my novel was
first done I saw multiple people uh
whose opinions I trusted their views on
what I had done like
just do what you're trying to do get the
opinions of people who you trust and who
you're willing to listen to
and if they are able to be honest with
you take whatever they say on board and
decide on the best way to move forward
so Primo Mega
thank you for the Super Chat as much as
fans praise Batman the anime Amendment
the Animated Series it seems like both
deeney and Tim have apathy for the late
80s 90s post crisis stuff not a fan of
their take on Bane their Bane was okay
it wasn't great but considering they
weren't going to do the storyline that
he was designed to facilitate it
probably was never going to be an
amazing take
um and yeah
that doesn't
surprise me at all you know they had
somewhat old school sensibilities I mean
the the art design for that thing was
you know was reminiscent of the max
Fleischer Superman uh cartoons for
crying out loud so like yeah I I would
agree with that
so I mean I guess whether or not that
impacts your viewing depends on on how
highly you personally hold the 80s and
90s uh post-crisis Batman from the
comics which
you know
idea for a regeneration Story the doctor
falls in uh with some human supremacists
and their fight against aliens only to
realize they've been subconsciously
sabotaging
uh it because doctor
hmm
it would be
personally would kind of like the
doctor's opinion of humans to get taken
down a peg or two every now and then
just I get
I get tired of
um
science fiction where like an alien or a
higher being or which the doctors kind
of both
um like Praises oh humans are so amazing
no we're not we're crap we are absolute
garbage
uh
oh well
255 A.D not that Super Chat John vinyls
is before mine no I talked about that
that so that led me down a rather
extended thing talking about uh
corporate culture and Disney and
comparing Disney to other things and how
I wish I didn't have to praise Disney
but a lot of other companies are so much
worse no no that set me on a whole
spiral I I did that one
in my opinion seven becomes more
manipulative in preparation to fight
fenrik the changes start when he meets
Ace he said he recognized friend Rick's
hand in it from the beginning I mean
sure but I don't like curse of Frederick
that much so while I won't dispute that
reading I don't favor it
uh
am I saying it's the friends of horror
yeah sure why not
uh the Grassroots campaign to get Andrea
uh reisborough and Oscar nomination
worked but at the expense of both
Danielle deadweiler and Viola Davis
uh till is absolutely heartbreaking I
don't I don't know a lot about that one
so I don't personally have an opinion
there
uh let's see where
did I leave off
to do
I have sympathy for child stars
yeah to a degree
I I don't
um
I don't doubt that
a lot of them probably would have chosen
to stop
what they were doing given the option
given like a true proper choice
am I planning to do a 10 Gallifrey one
this year no I'm too broke and I would
have had to have gotten my ticket months
ago yeah no I I just I can't afford it
foreign
[Music]
will there be any more episode of Liz
breaks Vera's brain
maybe
um
all right I I suppose
uh this is about as good a time as as
any Dimension because it's it's been a
little while now
um
uh Liz and I are not seeing each other
um as partners
any longer
um
it's it's
one of those things where it's just
um
you know it's private but at the same
time you know the fact that we were
together was public knowledge so it was
it was gonna come up
eventually and at this point it's been
some months
[Music]
um
and probably about time to
to cross the
uh the bridge on that
um
yeah now that having been said uh we're
not ruling out the possibility of her
breaking me with more Riverdale uh she
has said even in the not so uh
not so distant past that you know she'd
still like to break me with some of the
superhero stuff that goes on
good grief so that that may still happen
but
I think there is no
uh guarantee and no one should have
expectations of Liz appearing on either
this Channel or the break room of Geeks
going forward
again uh not impossible but obviously uh
uh circumstances have changed he didn't
do the hard thing I'm not sure which one
I didn't do it do it to 255 if if it was
to you uh 255 A.D then I apologize and
here it is if it was to John here's
another one if it was to Supreme Omega
here you go again and also for your new
Super Chat that you just got in uh also
on Batman the Animated Series do you
feel the whole uh Bruce Barber ship was
weird yes
yes it was always weird it was weird and
freaking what was it uh Batman
um and Mr Freeze Sub-Zero which is where
I'm pretty sure it first got floated as
a thing it was weird immediately it was
weird and creepy and I don't know why
Bruce Tim wouldn't let it go nobody like
nobody but him liked it
not good
huh
Terry Pratchett had humans sust when he
wrote about the Fallen Angel meets the
rising ape
yeah yeah kind of uh
all right let me see here
uh
so that's why you've gone off on 10.
stop banging on how much you love humans
you idiot we suck it's a con it's a
contributing factor sure
uh as a fan of DC Comics and Steven
Universe I would love to see a crossover
between the Crystal Gems and the Green
Lanterns like imagine the interactions
between someone like Guy Gardner oh God
he would get his butt kicked and it
would be great
where did you get your shivay pen and do
they have a heave version
this came from an Etsy store I don't
know the name of it off the top of my
head this was actually a gift from
Carolyn who's in the chat
um and I believe they do I believe I
looked at that at another Point later
because somebody else had asked a little
while back and as assuming the store is
still up last time I looked at it they
did have he they had they had all they
had the full range pretty much
uh
let's see
foreign what did you think of the DC
Ruby crossover was a weird one I didn't
even know that it happened so
uh no opinion
sending you much love Yeah it I I
appreciate that folks it's I mean it's
just
uh
things go in different directions we
move forward
if it helps there's other explanations
for Seven's Arc big finish implied he
was aware of the time War the books he's
scared of becoming the valiard
interesting takes
do I have rabbits in the area Oh you
mean like wild oh yeah yeah yeah I've
seen I've seen some every now and then
honestly you're more likely to see a
skunk though
so
there's that
the biggest stops are the officer oh my
gosh
the biggest Oscar upset for me this year
is Brett Morgan's Bowie collage
moonage Daydream not getting into the
final five documentary nominations
I didn't see that one trailer did look
good though
I'm slogging through Plato's dialogues
why
why for it was that like for a class or
something homebody why why why would you
do that
uh
let's see here
is the live in two different places
seems to be reading out chats I can't
see here well I'm looking at the live
chat if you only have top chat which I
can't figure out how the hell it decides
what it's going to show you're getting a
curated list curated by a metric I don't
understand
oh she's just further back than I'm
expecting yeah like I'm I'm re I'm
rarely caught up
so there you go
ironically it's the year of the rabbit I
would say fittingly it's the ear of the
rabbit that is not particularly ironic
sorry I can be a pennant over uh
misapplication of the term irony
Jesse
Jesse you
hope you're doing well
skunk or black cat with painted white
stripe oh no no we get we get legit
skunks around here of a fair bit I'm
currently watching the web Planet due to
another YouTuber I follow saying it's
their favorite first doctor story it's
certainly ambitious for its time I'll
say that I have not seen that one yet it
will be interesting when I do
really struggling with my HRT regimen on
pills what do you think of the patches
considering switching I mean the
patched obviously it's
I I still have to set a an alert on my
phone to remind myself to change it once
a week but you know it's not something
that I have to remember every day it's
just there
um it has its little annoyances
um depending on how sensitive your skin
is it can leave a little ring like for a
while like you're you I mean you
shouldn't anyway but you know you you
can't apply it to the same place uh over
and over again so like you move it a
little over to the side or you you put
it on your on your back side as opposed
to your lower stomach which is the other
place where it's good for and you know
you just notice this little collection
of fading red rings from having had it I
don't mind
um
so as long as you don't have super
sensitive skin
um yeah no they're not too bad
um they can be they can be a little bit
irritating if they start to peel in the
corner especially like if you're
showering
um or something like that but um I do
find that
um
you know just put on
put on something snug over them to just
hold them in place for a while they'll
re-stick they'll re-adhere
um so yeah
I'm fine with it I mean the main the
main reason I started on the patch was
twofold you tend to get results a little
bit faster than on the pill not as fast
as injections but a little bit faster
than on the pill and
um it's slightly lower
um instances of blood clots
um not hugely but like a little a little
bit lower instance of that
dude
[Music]
I just like esoteric philosophy I also
enjoyed uh so I can't read that
uh something uh about Buddhism
cool I will never appropriately
pronounce that so yeah
foreign
excuse me
Dusty Smith's entire YouTube channel has
been deleted I don't know if I know
Dusty Smith
it's usually a bad day anytime anyone's
channel gets fully deleted as a general
rule
I think
it's
uh I'm an ox
we got rats
I'm a [__] good to know Meg uh I'm a dog
for the record if we're talking uh
Chinese year Zodiacs yes I'm a dog
wolf
uh have you seen any controversial queer
material High Guardians Of Ice Cube
Force the webcomic boyfriend I mean I I
have a real bad gauge on what is or
isn't controversial anymore like
especially at this point you can look at
the video I did on book challenges and
Bannings that like just being visibly
queer at all has become controversial so
I don't I wouldn't even know how to
grade on that I haven't uh taken in any
of the things you listed
um so I'm gonna Hazard a guess to say no
I mean most material
I support the existence of
confrontational queer material stuff
that is very in your face with being
queer
I however don't enjoy most of it you
know as uh as someone partaking of the
art I tend to like
queer theming integrated into a story
that still works if the metaphor wasn't
there or if the coding wasn't there or
if
um those specific themes were something
else the core narrative would still
interest me it's kind of the same
approach I take to Comedy I don't tend
to like comedies that are just trying to
make you laugh not that there's anything
wrong with them but I have a very very
strong preference for comedies that are
telling a story that I would happily uh
follow even if it wasn't funny and then
it's funny on top of that I kind of feel
the same way with queer material I would
like a story that seems interesting and
engaging to me in and of itself and then
has queerness uh as like just a way for
me to enjoy it even more
so yeah that's sort of my roundabout way
of answering that John vineholz oh
because I brought up irony it's like
rain on your wedding day it's a free
ride
ah here's the thing
here's the layers to that
not a single
example
that Alanis Morissette gives in the song
Ironic is actually an example of irony
and that fact is ironic
there you go
uh
let's see where did I leave off
at least they nominated armist this year
yeah for blonde
that's also on the list of I'll only
watch it if somebody pays me good grief
uh
going back to Steven Universe meets
Green Lantern I can see Steven looking
at how Jordan and Jon Stewart as the
adults in the room whereas Kyle and guy
are brothers if that makes sense yeah
kind of I I feel like
um actually I feel like guy might oddly
bond with amethyst
they're they're both kind of terrible
people uh
uh
well
do I like the 15th doctor's pink beanie
I'm sorry is what now
that what
I feel like I missed something while I
was away
what
all right I'm not seeing what you're
talking about here
no I think you're yanking my chain
that's what I think you're doing
my opinion on Sword in the Stone it's
good I haven't rewatched in a long time
but it's good it's fun it's very
um
episodic it's a movie that certainly
wouldn't be made on the way it exists uh
uh now but I enjoy it that's a fun one
uh
uh so soteriology okay
I need you to say bread
properly which I probably just messed up
now
uh Q4 has a character on ironically
named twink that's how bad the show was
ah yeah I kind of hate that
I kind of hate that [__]
yeah yeah that's that stuff can
that stuff can piss off I don't like
that nonsense
I considered it a good omen that it's
the year of the rabbit we're getting the
finale of Sailor Moon this year
I did not realize Sailor Moon was still
running
wow okay that's
that is news to me all right all right
won't this stream get demonetized if I
sing if I sing too much it will sure
foreign
Banks Terry Pratchett they're two of my
faves even though I prefer Banks ha that
my brain won't
um process that comparison because
they're
they are so fundamentally different as
writers in terms of the narrative voice
that they're going for they both nail
what they're trying to do
but
I
I can't even
think of how to start to compare them
I feel like they both they both succeed
in what they're aiming for so well that
I think it largely comes down to a
matter of personal preference
preferentially I'm gonna favor Pratchett
a little but that's partially because
Pratchett reminds me of Douglas Adams
and Douglas Adams might be my favorite
writer ever so
I don't know that's oh that's a
difficult comparison though
dead end deserved better it did at least
the graphic novels are getting a
re-release
um later this year and so we can read
what probably would have been the
premise for more seasons uh if it had
gotten it which you know it's cold
comfort but
sometimes you take what you can oh and
uh heart for you John vinyls thank you
very much Aaron oh thank you quite
generous I really appreciate that just
popping in to say hi sorry I'm missing
things been working since I got uh home
from work no end in sight blarg hey all
well thank you for stopping in Aaron and
thank you for the Super Chat I greatly
appreciate it
foreign
just want to say sorry to hear about you
and Liz wishing both of you the best
thank you
thank you I'm I'm hoping for the best
for both of us too
I wonder how many uh
uh view how many people's negative views
of capitalism came from the character of
money bags on the Spyro games I never
played them so not had no impact on mine
certainly I felt bad for the squirrel
who saved Arthur's life in the movie
yeah she yeah she kind of got a bum deal
uh
uh I said both perfectly Oh yay go me
I did not get any images of shittigatwa
in a pink beanie but a lot of people are
searching it as soon as I type 50 Dr top
suggestion was 15th doctor pink beanie
ah good grief
uh
gotta go for lunch well thank you for
stopping in
always good to see you
uh
Discord yes I will get to that in one
moment Carolyn
um question have you ever read her have
you ever
question have you ever heard of Angel's
egg in the aftermath it is widely
considered the worst anime adaptation uh
worse than Dragon Ball Evolution and
Netflix Bebop I have not heard of either
the original or the adaptation
oh well
uh popping over to the Discord to
address questions there from patreon
supporters so
um if you ever want to take part uh and
get questions in early over there that
is how you can do so the Discord is a
patreon exclusive perk I will get
through these as quickly as I can here
we go
if you lived in the UK how would you
feel about having to pay the license fee
I've heard some people most of them
queer say they're going to stop paying
the license fee to protest the BBC being
transphobic maybe it's not my place to
have a say on this I'm suspect I
personally think that would be like
saying it's okay not to pay your taxes
to protest the government so I I don't
know I would be incredibly torn on that
because I actually do believe in the
value of a publicly funded
um
uh Network like the BBC but
I honestly don't know I honestly don't
know what I would do in that situation I
would be incredibly torn because it
would be a case of something that I
believe in the principle of stabbing me
in the back I mean much more so than is
already the case
um
uh so I don't I don't have a firm answer
one of the culture books you've not read
uh has a non-sequential chapter order
that can make it hard to get through
when Banks originally wrote it in the
1970s it apparently had an even more
confusing structure I think he had the
idea that the most climatic climactic
chapters would be in the middle and the
least climactic would be at the start
and end so basically the end of the
story would be in the middle of the book
in the early Parts would be at the start
and the end of the book Bank shows the
manuscript to another writer who told
them it was terrible so we shelved it
until the early 90s when he rewrote it
in a way that's actually readable do you
think any writer I.E anyone who's not an
unpublished 20 year old could make
something like that actually work like
just based on that description could you
imagine a book with a structure actually
enjoyable to read
foreign
yes
but
you would have to very specifically
build the narrative around the fact that
that's how you're doing it I think if
you just had a narrative had a story
that initially just lays out
in a standard progression and just tried
to shuffle the order of events
that will never work
if you built the story from the ground
up with the anticipation of doing it in
that format so that you are you even
knowing that that's how you're doing it
you are building the story in a way that
makes that easier to transition through
and maybe has themes that uh will
resonate with the idea that it is
climaxing in the middle I don't know
what those themes would be but those
sorts of things
possible
incredibly difficult to the point that I
would think in most cases probably not
worth the effort but possible in your
video about a Hogwarts Legacy you are
critical of yourself for buying clothes
that were made in sweatshops don't you
think that's a bit different since
clothes are an essential whereas video
games are not like there's a different
degree of sacrifice oh yeah of course
it's not a one-to-one
um and for clarity folks that is a video
that is actually not out yet that will
be out Saturday but again patreon
supporters get Early Access
um
yeah no that's it's not a one-to-one
comparison but it's just a way to
illustrate that at this point global
capitalism has tainted everything
so you'll note I also make the
comparison you know to the various toys
on the Shelf
none of those are Essentials so
that's probably a it's probably a
cleaner comparison
um Oscar schmaskers everything
everywhere is the most nominated do you
think it can win any major categories I
think uh uh
kahui Quan might be the best shot in the
big five I think he's got a shot I think
Michelle yo has a shot
the
I think the directors might win I'll be
more surprised if the movie does it
might be a case where the directors win
but the movie doesn't which doesn't
happen super often but happens more off
it happens more often in the last 20
years than it used to
Oscar schmosker's part two till and for
example Selma previously are largely
ignored is the academy scared to even
highlight films that Focus the Civil
Rights area era from an African-American
perspective
I don't
I don't yes but uh yes but it's not as
orchestrated as that it's not like
they're collectively holding meetings
and going we're not okay with this
it's just a matter of the you know the
academy itself being not as diverse as
it should be being
um and it being
you know having too many members that
are frankly old a little bit like
uh US Government sort of thing and being
stuck in an old way of doing things and
not open to different ways of doing
things and sometimes stuff breaks
through and
oftentimes
I get the feeling oftentimes with the
Oscars that they'll have some things
break through and they'll think and
theirs are awesome diversity stuff and
we don't have to think about all the
rest is the impression I get sometimes
uh given the maximum of no taxation
without representation is meant to be so
much part of American history and
identity Why is non-citizen voting in
local elections not more common in the
US as it is pretty usual for local type
elections in much of Europe and the UK
inspired by reading about this being
upheld in Montpelier
um so
non-citizen voting gets to be a very
dicey subject very quickly and it varies
wildly
from state to state and part of it has
to do and like first of all it's worth
pointing out
non-non-citizen does not mean
um in the country illegally there are
plenty of residential non-citizens here
legally in addition to migrants who most
of whom are here on Lee were originally
here on legal means that expired or what
have you
it
it gets dicey especially these days with
the right getting as up in arms about
Integrity of the vote which is a smoke
screen for we want to control who gets
to actually vote it
the thing is like most things in the U.S
it is mantric to the degree that it
doesn't actually get examined
in the same way that all men are created
equal is Mind Trick but doesn't get
examined in the same way as liberty and
justice for all is mantric but doesn't
actually get examined people just say it
as if it's true and leave it at that
uh how was the burlesque event over the
weekend it was good it was draining I
took one class I took a uh a floor work
class I actually bought knee pads
specifically to be able to to do that
class that was fun
I would like to integrate more floor
work into some of my numbers floor work
is so
hot
oh
so many numbers that I've seen that just
left me going
have incorporated or been primarily
floor work
oh God
who will be a good method of looking up
local to us burlesque events
um
depends where you are I suppose
I mean just start by looking up in your
state you know burlesque in whatever the
state is figure out where the pockets of
it are
um like in Vermont it's mostly in
Burlington with a couple of outliers
um and then
start following them following those
organizations and or venues on social
media and
uh see when things are scheduled for
that's probably the best way to start
have you ever heard of the comic Atomic
Robo I have I've never read it though
it's a comic series that follows the
titular Atomic Robo a snarky robot made
by Nikola Tesla of course who runs a
company and has Adventures across the
decades from the time of his creation to
present days basically a Sci-Fi version
of Hellboy just replace Witchcraft and
folklore enemies with super science the
Creator described the tone as taking the
Indiana Jones style of archeology and
applying it to implying that to every
field of science so you've got
physicists punching out terrorists plus
one of the villains is the ghost of
Thomas Edison so that's just great I
have heard of atomic Robo I have some
friends who swear by it I have never
read it apparently Finn Jones wants to
get another crack at Iron Fist
like I feel bad and I get that the
script was bad and that the shooting was
bad and like nothing about that show was
good but like dude
you weren't good in the part like I
would have been okay with Thomas Jane
getting another crack of the Punisher
because while I actually don't even
think that movie's that all that bad
it's just not a great representation of
the character
um but he was still decent in it like
Finn Jones was just not
good in the part he just wasn't he
wasn't
he wasn't
while the iron fish show had numerous
problems I honestly thought Finn Jones
was a good pick for Danny Rand I thought
he was insufferable
I kind of hated him he was an annoying
little prick and I get that's actually
meant to be part of the character but he
couldn't balance it with any charm to
make him like an enjoyable
like Tony Stark's an enjoyable prick
Danny Rand was not Danny Rand was in
sufferable and yes a lot of that wasn't
Finn Jones's fault but no part of any of
what I saw from him made me think he was
elevating the material
made me think that he was bringing
anything to it
like
a fair amount of problems with the uh
with the Luke Cage Seasons as well there
were a lot I didn't like about either of
them I would still love for him to come
back and play Luke Cage again because he
was real good in the park Finn Jones
just wasn't
he wasn't I'm sorry
he wasn't I don't think so that having
been said if he was if he's given
another chance I'll give him a shot and
I would love to be proven wrong about
that I would love to be wrong
I um
if it was my decision I would move on to
somebody else
uh honestly if it was my decision I'd
just pick up with Colleen wing and
abandon Danny completely she's a more
interesting character regardless but
whatever with John Kent Superman's son
who's been aged up to 17 being bisexual
would you say he would be more impactful
if he was still 10 years old I've seen
plenty of people say that the Aging up
should stick however I feel like him
going back to his original age of 10
would be better on that front since
there is a strong lack of showcasing
innocent crushes and puppy love for
younger males and showing the
wholesomeness that can be found there it
might just be me but I've noticed for a
long time that same-sex female
relationships are the ones being
showcased more while I think Owen is a
win it would be nice to see more from a
male Mass presenting side of things
um
I get what you're saying my own personal
opinion is to kind of run hard the other
way which is that I don't think we
should be delving into the sexuality of
any 10 year olds in most of our media
I think that is done
way too damn much
I think the codification of oh the
childhood Crush regardless of who it is
is
exhausting and kind of gross
like and I mean that with with
heterosexual like I see I see things
with freaking
10 year old characters in whether it's a
cartoon or it's live action like getting
all these little giggly crushes on
somebody I don't care who it is I find
it off-putting
just don't like it
so that's kind of where I'm at I would
scrap most of it but having said that at
the same time I do recognize that it is
an age where crushes actually do start
to form and I can't actually other than
my own personal tastes make a core
argument as to why we shouldn't have it
at all and if it is going to exist for
straight uh crushes it should exist for
um same-sex crushes and uh anything else
on the queer spectrum and I do agree
with you at least in my own General
sense is that
by and large especially in any media
aimed at a younger audience girl on girl
crushing is more appears to be more
acceptable there are exceptions and even
some fairly recently like with Disney's
Strange worlds although again admittedly
he was in his later
excuse me he was later teens I don't
know if they
establish his actual age
but yeah I'm kind of of the opinion uh I
don't really want to see 10 year olds
crushing on anybody but if you're gonna
do it a more even spread would be nice
okay I'm now back to the main chat I'm
out of the Discord let's catch up
John vinyls thank you very much for the
uh Super Chat what makes the Oscars
frustrating is they're often the only
chance a lot of international films have
to break through in the U.S that is
uh frustratingly true yeah that
it
it would be nice if it like was a very
it was a cleaner thing of like
they definitely get more notice
and some and to some degree they do
but you know uh
this is partially the thing is this is
partially U.S problem but this is also
partially you know the US also exports a
lot of its entertainment it's it's the
core of a lot of the biggest
entertainment in the entire world so
yeah we tend to
focus on what we produce which is
unfortunate and that is just kind of
reflective of a U.S mentality in general
uh trig from Ireland thank you very much
for the Super Chat is being quote
unquote terminally online actually a Bad
Thing media criticism for social media
has a certain tone to it that I
sometimes find unsettling
um
so the way in which
your question is kind of cyclical
because you're saying is being
terminally online actually a Bad Thing
whereas sort of by its nature that
specific term is generally used to
indicate the times when being online has
gotten so has gotten to the point of
becoming a Bad Thing therefore you use
that term but does that necessarily mean
that anyone who spends a lot of time
online is it a bad thing hopefully
ideally in that situation you wouldn't
use the phrase terminally online
uh it it can turn into an argument over
pedantic
um
definitions
and
I
don't think that a
that there is an inherent
wickedness or detriment to having a
significantly online existence
I do think for most
people
it is a good idea to maintain
um real world touch points I do I say
that while recognizing
um
I say that while recognizing that for
some people be it some people with
certain physical limitations be it some
people with certain or divergences be it
some people just in situations where
they don't have they're not in a safe
physical environment and online spaces
are just going to be better for them
than the real world situation they're
actually in I understand that there are
exceptions for all those reasons I I do
feel that when the term comes up it
usually at least in the times I've seen
it is in reference to the pretty
specific stripe of online life that
comes in the form of people who
would have
um more touch points in their life if
they allowed that to happen but they are
cutting things off in order to be more
online I do think that there is a excuse
me there's a difference between
just building a very online existence
for yourself
and you know just as a thing to do and
be and cutting off
other ways of interacting with people
um in order to do that I that and it's
the latter that I feel like that term is
usually in reference to
um obviously this is not meant for every
instance that the reference is used but
it's a it's a it's a phrase you see very
often
in reference to far-right spaces
um the alt-right is frequently referred
to as being terminally online and there
are reasons for that because they are so
insulated and insular in their
um
in their interactions that they use what
basically feels like a foreign language
of inside terminology abbreviations and
meme references to communicate with each
other that is impenetrable to anybody
from the outside so there's that aspect
and then also somewhat specific to the
far right is the idea of they are often
encouraged to disassociate from making
real world connections because real
world connections would uh put a lie to
a lot of the stuff that they're being
fed you know the things they're supposed
to hate and the things that uh they're
meant to support
and I would caution anyone
applying the phrase terminally online
outside of that specific bubble I'm not
going to say it can't have use outside
of that but I feel like the term came
into heavy use to refer to that specific
subculture and I do think it is pretty
fairly applied there
it's not a phrase I'd want to see
proliferated too far outside of that of
referencing that particular media
internalized media bubble because it it
starts to lose the meaning of what it
was actually referring to if that makes
sense all right I'm going to try and
catch up on the super chats and we are
going to wrap it up soon
um
can Panic at the Disco technically be a
band if they only consist of one guy
yeah sure
I consider Harry Nielsen a band he was
one guy uh Supreme
Omega I wonder why adaptations are
uncomfortable at using Oracle compared
how much they adapt Nightwing is it
because of issues surrounding the
killing joke
possibly I think well I think now part
of it is that Oracle just is no longer
the case I think where it was
um particularly
um noticeable was back in the years
before the new 52 when that's who
Barbara was and they and none of the
adaptations would cover getting up to
that point even if you choose to skip
over
um the
um
uh the actual events that caused her to
be in a wheelchair a lot of use could
have still been made of her and wasn't
these days I suspect they just use the
uh excuse of like well I mean she's not
in it now so we're just referencing the
more Karen
but they seem very happy to have the
excuse to not deal with it
uh I don't
I think there is a there's a discomfort
with
um atypical periods for these characters
and
a lot of adaptations tend to avoid them
255 a d thank you very much for the
Super Chat there that question by Young
Banks how do you handle telling a young
writer you think this is clever but I'm
reading it as incomprehensible nonsense
um
I mean it would be incredibly dependent
on what kind of relationship I had to
that person and ideally I would know how
to communicate so that person would best
hear it
um
but basically kind of just what you said
like I see what you did structure wise
and that's really interesting
what purpose does it serve why did you
structure it like this would probably be
where I start before just sleeping into
saying it's incomprehensible nonsense
because I feel like I would have to try
and parse what was the actual goal in
doing that was there something you were
trying to accomplish because if I could
understand that other than just I think
it's a neat way to tell a story at that
point it would go okay it's an
incoherent way nice try it doesn't work
but if they actually had a goal they
were attaining for then maybe I'd be
able to say okay I don't think this
accomplishes that goal maybe have you
considered this or that or something
else
um again it'd be probably very
situational
where are we
Scully made me gay ah bless Agent Scully
uh that's yep I think she did that for a
lot of people Meg
[Laughter]
I as Carolyn points out valid
trig
ger thank you once again with the Super
Chat I very much appreciate your
thoughtful answer my somewhat off topic
question thank you of course of course
I'd like
foreign it's pretty rare that I don't
have some thoughts unless somebody
unless somebody asks me an opinion on
something that I don't know about
um but you know
a rambling brain will uh wind it up and
watch it go but anyways I think we are
we are gonna wrap it up I have filming
to do
um and some stuff to get done oh
John vinyl sneaking in at the last
minute
um thank you very much I would love to
have rain Whispers at my wedding I bet
they they would make uh an awesome
accompanist for the ceremony itself or
for the reception
so yes stuff coming up tomorrow will be
the latest take two Doctor Who review uh
this one will be on the haunting of
villa Dia Daddy and I have a feeling I'm
gonna tick some people off
with that one
we'll see
um after that uh there will be I'll also
be streaming on Twitch tomorrow morning
um and also
uh Friday tomorrow I'm probably gonna
wrap up playing lost in play after that
I don't know
um I've got a number of options I gotta
figure that out Carol and we need to
talk about that we need to sort that
um so and then
um
Saturday's video
is on a lot of stuff but it is
essentially talking about
the notion of hollow allyship people who
say with their words I support
uh you know trans people or whatnot but
then through their actions will not
actually take a stand so that's the
primary focus of the conversation
unfortunately
yet again filtered through the lens of
at least touching on
JK Rowling ah I'm so sick of it I'll be
actually I'll be really happy when that
damn game comes out and people will
hopefully talk a bit less about her I
feel like that I feel like Hogwarts
Legacy coming out is really really
kicked the beehive on this
eternal sailor Earth thank you very much
for the Super Chat I appreciate that
very much a more manga faithful remake
called Sailor Moon Crystal was released
starting in 2014. the anime adaptation
of the fifth and final Arc of the manga
comes out in June under the name Sailor
Moon Cosmos interesting I have not ever
really seen all that much
um of Sailor Moon I've seen bits and
pieces like I get when people reference
it I get what they're referencing I've
not
I have not seen much of it I do have to
admit oh is this the front yes I Angus
it is the one that's that sort of starts
by talking about
uh Stephen Fry how do you feel about
vosh saying it's okay to buy the game I
do not give two craps what vosh thinks
about
literally anything
and that's not even me disagreeing with
him I don't care what his opinion is I
just I don't
I do not
I do not care what it is
nor do I have a rebuttal to it I don't
care
I have no interest in his opinion
somebody tried to link his V well no
somebody did I let it through somebody
linked his video to my short that I put
up earlier today I'm not gonna watch it
I don't care what he thinks
I really really don't
if you want to boil down his argument
and regurgitate it as your own maybe if
I'm in a good mood I'll deal with that
I'm not watching I'm not watching that I
do not care what he thinks
foreign
something wrong with vosh I have no
interest in him
like that's it that's it
a lot plenty of people have problems
with him some people do some people
don't some people defend him some people
did I don't care
aggressive I aggressively do not care
ah
anyways
that's it that's it we're wrapping it up
thank you everybody for joining me thank
you for the uh support thank you for
listening to my rambling nonsense thank
you for being here
just thank you
I hope that everybody has a wonderful
rest of the week
um and I hope that you
just
are well
I hope that you be well you be safe and
you be kind
because you're beautiful you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
mccavity